bienvenue à tous et leurs deux
parlements hebdo 45 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire à mes côtés comme chaque
semaine catalyseur bonjour bonjour ni
quelle est cette semaine dans
l'actualité françois hollande abat sa
dernière carte contre le chômage le chef
de l'état a présenté ses ultimes mesure
du quinquennat en faveur de l'emploi
sans surprise ce plan a vivement été
critiquée par l'opposition
l'état d'urgence sera t'il prolongé
c'est au président de la république d'en
décider mais c'est tout à fait probable
selon claude bartolone reçu à l'elysée
avec son homologue gérard larcher pour
évoquer la révision de la constitution
émeutes chez les photographes et
déclarations sexistes de quelques
députés s'étaient alerte à l'assemblée
cette semaine l'actrice canadienne
pamela anderson est venu dans
l'hémicycle à débourser les souffrances
des canards et des oies dans l'élevage
français de production de foie gras on
en parle dans cette émission et on en
parle avec quelle nicolas dupont aignan
qui est notre invité cette semaine
bonjour un bonjour vous êtes député de
l'essonne et président de debout la
france partie que vous avez fondé on en
parlera mais vous commenterez
l'actualité dense de cette semaine à
commencer par vingt dix et on y va on
commence avec les annonces de françois
hollande c'est en quelque sorte une
nouvelle boîte à outils qui a présenté
françois hollande pour lutter contre le
chômage on en connaissait les grands
principes
voici le détail avec julie lui il veut
faire de la lutte contre le chômage sa
priorité
je considère que face aux désordres du
monde face à une conjoncture économique
incertaine et un chômage persistant
il y a aussi un état d'urgence
économique et social a proclamé les mots
sont forts les annonces plus attendus
première mesure concernant la
compétitivité une prime d'embauché de
2000 euros par an pour les entreprises
de moins de 250 salariés qui
embaucheront en cdi ou en cdd d'au moins
six mois à condition que le salaire ne
dépasse pas 1,3 smic
une mesure qui prend effet dès
aujourd'hui ce dispositif
est établi pour une durée de deux ans
pourquoi deux ans c'est le temps du
basculement du cic eux en baisse
définitive de charge autre volet celui
de la formation avec un plan de 1
milliard d'euros pour former cinq cent
mille chômeurs des formations liées
branche par branche régions par régions
aux besoins des entreprises
l'enjeu c'est de pourvoir les emplois
disponibles et qui ne trouve pas preneur
faute de personnels qualifiés en nombre
suffisant françois hollande souhaite
également une augmentation des contrats
de professionnalisation qui devrait
passer à 50 mille bénéficiaires contre
8000 actuellement enfin évoqué ce matin
la future réforme du code du travail qui
accordera aux entreprises de nouveaux
assouplissements sur le temps de travail
sans toucher à la durée légale de 35
heures un plan contre le chômage estimé
à plus de 2 milliards d'euros uniquement
financée par des économies alors nicolas
dupont aignan sa cent mille chômeurs aux
formations vous avez certainement me
dire que c'est peut-être pour déguiser
les chiffres quoi qu'il en soit fait
quand même une bonne nouvelle pour ceux
qui sont dans cette situation il est
sincère le plan de france en blanc mais
c'est pathétique
cg je la commande de tristesse quand je
vois ça parce que je pense à ces
millions de chômeurs quand je pense
qu'il ya des mesures qu'on attend depuis
des années d'ailleurs sous les
gouvernements de droite aussi qu'ils ne
sont pas prises qu'on en est au 25e plan
pour l'emploi
quand je pense que vous avez des
dizaines de milliers d'entreprises
d'artisans de pme qui font faillite
parce qu'il ya cinq cent mille
travailleurs détachés en france qui ne
payent pas les charges sociales
françaises c'est une concurrence
déloyale
quand je pense que mes amis douaniers
ouvrent des containers au havre qui sont
plein de produits chinois qui ne
respectent pas les normes européennes
qu'on impose à nos entreprises
je me dis mais mais c'est scandaleux de
voir ça mais c'est une honte ce qui se
passe c'est qu'il ya des mesures à
prendre
immédiate mais qu'elle abat très simple
très simple j'annule la directive
travailleurs détachés tous salariés
roumains polonais espagnols portugais
qui vient en france paiera les charges
sociales françaises
quand on réforme par exemple quand on
change les fenêtres d'un hôpital et
qu'on fait venir par une société
luxembourgeoise des esclaves qui ne
payent pas les cotisations sociales
françaises
c'est une concurrence déloyale nos
encres et on passe au premier poteau
deuxième point je contrôle les produits
qui rentrent dans notre pays troisième
point mesures concrètes
je divise par deux l'impôt sur les
sociétés pour tous les bénéfices
réinvestis sur le sol français
c'est à dire je fais une prime forte à
l'investissement des entreprises
quatrième point je réforme le rsi pour
eux
dynamiser nos petits artisans voilà des
mesures non ils arrêtent de l'adula
brenner programme odyssée tellement plus
vous avez des voix la rue vous avez dit
oui c'était de nous on est ce qui est
honteux le mécano après son élection
avec 630 mille chômeurs de plus nicolas
sarkozy un million de chômeurs de plus
françois hollande 630000 et maintenant
alors que des entreprises sont
délocalisés tous les jours que alstom a
été bradée que general electric annonce
des milliers de suppressions d'emplois
mais est-ce qu'on se rend compte de la
gravité de la situation et il ya un
point sur lequel de ces espèces de
pitreries au conseil économique et
social avec tous ces personnes qui
applaudissent comme ça alors que nos
compatriotes sont en train de crever sur
le banc d'arguin ya un point sur lequel
à l'arrière on est en train d'avancer
aussi dans les mentalités c'est
l'indemnisation des chômeurs vous avez
peut-être à emmanuel macron qui en a
parlé même bien sûr le gros atout charme
os qui les chômeurs sont trop indemnisés
en france mais trop longtemps trop trop
cher ça se dit socialiste est un
incapable de limiter le nombre de
chômeurs maintenant ils veulent réduire
les indemnités chômage ont tort oui ils
ont tort alors il ya eu des abus il faut
peut-être réduire certains abus mais
vous savez un gouvernement qui au bout
de quatre ans s'attaque aux chômeurs
parce qu'il n'a pas été capable d'aider
les entreprises à baisser les charges
parce qu'il n'a pas été capable de
protéger nos entreprises c'est un
gouvernement aux abois et vous savez les
français sont pas idiots ils voient bien
que c'est pas une prime de 2000 euros
qui va faire recruter les entreprises
c'est d'avoir une vie
ibilité sur le long terme moins de
charges et moins de déloyauté de
concurrence moi je suis pour la
concurrence est loyale vous l'avez
compris on a compris alors les mesures
du président la république pour l'emploi
ont été effectivement très commentée et
très kit risque est que ce soit à droite
comme à gauche écouter on ne peut pas
malheureusement former 500 mille
personnes
en plus on ne peut pas les formes et
puisque les emplois ne sont pas là
derrière verser une prime aux pme pour
qu'elles créent un emploi c'est quelque
chose que tout le monde a essayé 20 fois
et tout le monde sait tous les
économistes le reconnaissent ce sont des
mesures qui ont un effet d'aubaine pour
80 dans 90% des cas aujourd'hui mettre
deux milliards sur la table quand il en
faudrait évidemment 10 de plus c'est pas
à la hauteur il ya quand même une forme
de provocation une de plus remise en
cause des 35 heures mises en cause du
code du travail
plafonnement des indemnités prud'homale
ça va loin là ça commence à faire
beaucoup
alors nicolas dupont aignan vous venez
vous aussi de fustiger ce plan pour vous
il est absolument aucune bonne mesure de
l'eso plan quoi que fasse 30
il aura temps est tanné qu'on favorise
l'apprentissage je suis favorable
bien évidemment quand vous avez une
infection dont claude cottier à une
infection quand un malade à une
infection si vous lui donnez du
doliprane ou de l'aspirine pour pas
vendre une marque certes vous fait un
bon geste
vous lui faites tomber un peu la fièvre
mais si vous ne soyez pas la cause de la
fièvre
vous avez vu cette entreprise en
picardie à ham qui a taux de profits
importants qui est délocalisée sans que
personne ne bronche
est ce que vous voyez la réalité de
notre force vive qui est en train de
partir à l'étranger si on ne réagit pas
vite ça fait dix ans que ça dure on a eu
sarkozy
on a eu un ou les mélangeant exactement
joyet monsieur woerth il a fait ce qu'a
fait monsieur macron c'était un peu
mieux peut-être mais il ne traite pas
les causes du problème
tant qu'on ne remettra pas de la loyauté
dans la concurrence internationale
on crèvera sur place c'est tout on a
bien compris on va revenir si vous vous
bien sûr d
j'ai des parlementaires la droite a usé
cette semaine de son de droit de tirage
pour demander la création d'une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire
cette commission portera sur les moyens
déployés par l'état pour lutter contre
le terrorisme et pour détecter
d'éventuels dysfonctionnements et faye
écouter christian jacob
l'idée c'est d'avoir la transparence sur
les moyens mis à disposition pour lutter
contre le terrorisme et de regarder si
ces moyens ont été efficaces dans quel
cadre et l'évaluation qu'il est logique
de faire mais on est dans un travail de
fond n'est pas du tout dans un débat à
pau les polémiques de quelle que nature
que ce soit faisons la transparence et
faisons le avec avec serena est ce que
pour vous nicolas dupont aignan cette
commission d' enquête sur les attentats
est une bonne chose et ce qu'il faut
faire la lumière sur d'éventuelles zones
d'ombré dysfonctionnements coûteux ce
toujours l'honneur d'un parlement dans
une société démocratique apaisée
responsable que de savoir ce qui s'est
passé
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait améliorer moi
je crois beaucoup au travail
parlementaire
j'ai rédigé un rapport sur les paradis
fiscaux ça a été très bénéfique avec dos
de gauche de droite ça montrera
d'ailleurs aux français qu' ici dans ces
maisons on bosse et et 115 est bas les
français ne savent pas là heureusement
que de normal d'un code pendant 20 ans
résout pas les problèmes d'un peuple
il ya un moment c'est normal qu'il doute
pour autant il ya eu des tonnes de
rapport il ya tout dans les rapports et
vous êtes bien placé pour les étudier
ces rapports
mais donc j'aimerais que tous vos
confrères fasse pareil si tu laisses est
une autre affaire
il pas encore une commission de 2 choses
une commission pour mieux comprendre
anticiper sas aux états unis ça fait en
allemagne ça se fait en grande bretagne
très bien en revanche que j'ai dit à
monsieur jacob et aux autres c'est qu'il
ya quelques mesures et j'ai pris la
parole au congrès ça un peu remué quand
j'ai pris la parole parce que j'ai osé
rompre le le consensus
qu'ils étaient licenciés dans la douleur
mais quand même il ya des choses qui me
paraissent urgente c'est interpellé et
arrêté préventivement les jihadistes de
retour de syrie monsieur cazenove n'a
toujours pas précisé correctement dans
les réponses aux questions à l'assemblée
nationale dans les séances sur lequel
jacky j'imagine que c'est pareil au
sénat où étaient ces 250 g à 10 dont il
avait parlé on nous dit que certains
sont en prison mais en fait ils ont été
libérés j'aimerais avoir les chiffres le
problème c'est le retour le retour sur
le territoire français
c'est là où vous dites qu'il ya pas
assez de choses qui n'avaient cessé le
problème majeur c'est con à 250 bombes
volantes qu'on n'arrête pas
préventivement
or j'estime que quand on va couper des
têtes en syrie on a déjà commis un acte
grave alors il ya des procédures qui
sont lancés mais nous n'avons pas la
transparence là dessus deuxième point
moi je veux arrêter ces personnes les
maîtres et les éloigner sur un
territoire lointain je ne suis plus un
territoire d'outre-mer parce que je ne
veux pas vu que c'est certain mais
voulait me troue et il ya suffisamment
d'îlots perdu dans notre pays pour que
comme à guantanamo des gens qui sont
dangereux soient arrêtés et isolde aucun
guantanamo à la française je vais
toujours demander sous contrôle
judiciaire
parce que ça sert à rien de déchoir de
la nationalité et d'expulser à
l'étranger dix personnes par an si
parallèlement on laisse des français eux
djihadistes en liberté sur le solde
prévu que ça donne quoi ça a bien marché
et heureusement qu'ils l'ont fait au
moment de walter center
donc il ya un moment où on peut pas
laisser des bombes volantes sur notre
sol et puis enfin il faut s'attaquer
j'ai lu avec intérêt la tribune du chef
d'état-major des armées monsieur de
villiers
il faut s'attaquer au financement de
dèche
on commence à le faire péniblement
commence à faire est ce qui est curieux
voyez madame c'est que on dit qu'on le
fait mais l'union européenne avec la
complicité de la france
complicité j'emploie ce mot veut verser
trois milliards d'euros
un pays voyou la turquie qui achètent en
contrebande
le pétrole de dèche alors moi je veux
bien tout ce qu'il faudrait rompre avec
la turquie il faudrait un moment dire
stop à la turquie on peut pas fait dans
le temps mieux les alliés il faut
quand on est à lier si on a des alliés
comme ça sa complicité de l'amour dure
sévère
écoutez quand je vois que l'union
européenne comme seule réponse sur les
migrations et de donner de l'argent à un
état pour le moins ambigu vis-à-vis des
shows je me pose des questions on va
passer un autre sujet c'était cette fois
au sénat ça n'a rien à voir avec les
commissions d enquête sur le terrorisme
on va parler de la biodiversité c'est un
examen de cette loi au sénat son but
c'était de renforcer la prise en compte
de la biodiversité dans les décisions
publiques et privées ce texte avait été
examiné il ya près de 10 mois à
l'assemblée nationale écouté la ministre
de l'ecologie ségolène royal à ce propos
alors je sais que pour certains français
la biodiversité apparaît encore comme un
terme un peu abstrait quelque chose de
complexe c'est pourtant très concret la
biodiversité
ça concerne directement la santé de tout
un chacun car une nature malmené par le
dérèglement climatique et les pollutions
ce sont aussi des risques sanitaires
accrus
c'est pourquoi ce projet de loi intègre
la relation entre la santé et le bon
état de la biodiversité par exemple en
facilitant le recours au traitement
naturel de l'eau en interdisant leur
rejet en mer des eaux de ballast non
traitées texte très important pour la
france pour les français pour la nature
il aura mis presque quatre ans arrivé la
force des lobbys on l'a vu sur la chasse
on l'a vu sur les insecticides sa touche
tous les jours notre quotidien la force
des lobbies fait quand même
impressionnant oui c'est impressionnant
et c'est d'autant plus impressionnant
qu'on a confiées à bruxelles à une
commission vendu acheté tous ceux qui
ont été députés européens le savent les
règles des principales règles de notre
de notre vie et quand on voit ce qui se
passe sur les normes anti pollution des
voitures quand on voit ce qui se passe
sur les pesticides
quand on voit le lien entre les
pesticides et les cancers
quand on voit le rôle où le problème
c'est l'europe le problème de la france
tous ces sujets on est bien sûr
puisqu'on a confié le pouvoir
démocratique à des autorités qui ne sont
pas élus c'est pas l'europe en soit l'on
aura peut être une bonne chose que la
tension je suis souvent caricaturée on
va revenir sur l'europe c'est une
merveilleuse chossy
elle est légitime par le suffrage pas si
elle impose des lobbys des technocrates
qui ne font que madame royal fait ce
qu'elle peut comme les précédents
ministres l'environnement alors je vais
vous faire réagir à un autre sujet c'est
le premier grand texte qui était en
examen à l'assemblée le projet de loi
pour une république numérique il
s'appelle comme ça il prévoit notamment
l'accès pour tous au numérique
une ouverture de données de plus de 10
millions d'entreprises françaises
seraient accessibles de manière gratuite
pendant un an ce que vous êtes favorable
à ce genre de mesure à cette ouverture
oui je pense que je les fais dans ma
ville d'ailleurs je pense que c'est un
progrès la république transparence des
données très importantes pour autant il
ya encore beaucoup de chemin et le
projet de loi est très mais la façon
dont vert de la ministre de laisser un
petit peu les français s'expriment et
ses partenaires note senior enfin ça
c'est du grand folklore à m'excuser moi
parce qu'en même temps laisse les
français s'est exprimé mais on sait
comment les entreprises américaines ont
mis la main sur les données
on sait qu'il ya un immense travail à
faire sur la souveraineté numérique
il ya eu des écrits très intéressant
derrière les noës l'enjeu est pour nous
protéger
et puis des réseaux la suisse la suisse
à renationaliser les réseaux l'allemagne
a un ministère des réseaux nous sommes
très en retard en france sur eux
la conception de souveraineté nationale
pour protéger nos concitoyens et ça
transcende tous les partis je pense que
regarder ce qui se passe sur le
terrorisme vous avez des terroristes qui
utilisent les réseaux américains et les
grandes entreprises américaines qui
refuse à nos ministres de l'intérieur
comme aux américains d'ailleurs de
pouvoir savoir ce qui se passe sur c'est
sur ces réseaux donc on voit bien qu'ils
à nouveau monde et moi j'aimerais que la
politique et j'en parlerai de quelques
mois j'aimerais que la politique
française regardent peut-être un peu
plus loin le monde d'après à 20 ans à 30
ans comment on anticipe ce monde d'après
et si on ne s'investit pas
avec l'état et les européens d'ailleurs
ensemble pour défendre notre
souveraineté numérique et bien nous
serons les esclaves de google d'amazon
et délais aussi importante que la
souveraineté tous concernés les membres
souveraine mais la souveraineté c'est la
liberté d'un peuple
elle s'adapte avec les époques si on
n'est pas capable d'inventer
c'est comme si on n'avait pas inventé la
machine à vapeur et qu'on était toujours
aux chevaux et bien là on est en train
de louper une marche
alors mardi nicolas dupont aignan il ya
eu une image qui a fait les gros titres
une émeute à l'assemblée en cause la
présence de pamela anderson l'actrice
américaine est venue soutenir une
proposition de loi de la députée
écologiste laurence abeilles pour
interdire le gavage des oies et cette
visite a suscité beaucoup de critiques
est ce que pour vous qui qu'est-ce que
comment vous avez réagi à ce laps de la
politique spectacle pour vous ça vous à
voir l'intérêt c'est de la politique
spectacle et quand on voit les merdes
que manger américain pardonnez moi de
parler vulgairement sa manuel mais ça
veut dire que je savais c'est tellement
facile de vouloir détruire les terroirs
français
alors que on veut nous imposer un traité
transatlantique et j'aimerais que madame
henderson et la députée bahia bay nous
explique comment on va lutter contre le
traité la batterie qui va nous faire
manger il a écouté les poulets à l'eau
de javel
alors écoutons ce cas là cela paraît
beaucoup plus dangereux que fois la
cuisine la première image que l'on a de
la cuisine française c'est le gavage à
l'abattage de 80 millions de canards et
d'oies chaque année nous devons dépasser
la barbarie et l'ignorance et pour être
franche le foie gras est simplement un
foie malade et cette maladie s'appelle
cirrhose précieuse ce que ça veut dire
c'est que ces animaux sont forcés à
souffrir d'une inflammation and blessure
jusqu'à ce qu'on les abandonne sa très
hypocrite et je trouve que les députés
qui ont fait ça ferait mieux de
s'occuper de la négociation du traité
transatlantique ou là ce sont des boeuf
aux hormones
c'est une spirale positive une
agriculture industrielle
oui s'en occupe sauf que nous
parlementaires on n'a pas le droit de
lire le traité transat en encore est-ce
que vous avez vu j'ai écrit un billet de
blog
là dessus vous pouvez consulter sur mon
site debout la france où on voit comment
aujourd'hui on est traité en enfants
parce que une commission de bureaucrates
vendus à des gros intérêts industriels
négocient lé traité transatlantique dans
le dos du gouvernement français c'est
autrement plus graves que les oies alors
on peut peut-être améliorer la
production des oies je suis pas du tout
favorable à la souffrance des oies du
tout et puisque je me lis beaucoup pour
la vie animale priorité si c'est
important mais attention aux deux poids
deux mesures c'est tout ce que je
demande que madame henderson qu'il aille
voir les fermes américaines
ça serait bien mercredi nasri est l'état
d'urgence et françois hollande
envisagerait de prolonger l'état
d'urgence au-delà du 26 février c'est ce
qu'a laissé entendre le président de
l'assemblée claude bartolone reçu à
l'elysée avec gérard larcher pour
évoquer l'épineuse question de la
révision constitutionnelle
écoutez les à la sortie il a évoqué
d'une manière tout à fait probable nous
annoncer qu'il aura l'occasion de
communiquer très vite pour permettre au
conseil d'état et au parlement de ce
pont soul prononcer sur ce texte
je rappelle que le délai c'est avant le
26 février
est ce que pour vous il est nécessaire
de prolonger l'état d'urgence
au-delà du 26 février oui c'est
indispensable et c'est une affaire grave
car les forces de police et de
gendarmerie ont besoin d'être présente
sur le territoire sans freinage
judiciaire et quand on connaît la
justice française pour démanteler les
réseaux pour surveiller les caches
d'armes
c'est vital et donc je supplie le
gouvernement français de prolonger
l'état d'urgence et car moi je ne veux
pas qu'on se retrouve dans un mois dans
deux mois dans trois mois ou dans six
mois avec un nouveau massacre au coeur
d'une ville dans un train et qu'on se
dise on n'a pas fait ce qu'il fallait
c'est pourquoi je demande encore une
fois l'arrestation des djihadistes
d'euros
tour de syrie leur éloignement du
territoire métropolitain c'est pourquoi
je demande aussi l' isolement dans nos
prisons des islamistes j'ai été visité
la prison de villepinte pendant la
campagne régionale
quand je vois que circulent librement
dans nos prisons les prisonniers que
l'on mêle c'est dans cette prison qui
avait coulibaly d'ailleurs qu' il se
promène qui sont mêlées mais c'est
surréaliste ce convoi donc il faut
revoir notre loi pénale annulé abroger
la loi taubira
il faut construire des places de prison
il faut que madame taubira démission est
quasi question bah oui mais il faut être
cohérent
enfin c'est quoi ce qui se passe c'est
pas dire on a un président de la
république un premier ministre qui ont
le pied sur l'accélérateur
ça va pas assez loin voulait venir
arrêter mais c'est mieux que rien
j'avais proposé d'état d'urgence en
janvier ils l'ont fait en neuf ans donc
c'est mieux que rien mais on a un garde
des sceaux qui a le pied sur le fera et
qui est responsable avec le gouvernement
de cette fameuse loi qui remplace
l'incarcération par des peines
alternatives pour les peines de moins de
5 des condamnations de cinq ans et moins
qui laisse dans notre pays des voyous
terroriser les populations
je parle de ce que je connais dans ma
ville et ailleurs mais c'est fou ce qui
se passe donc je demande que madame
taubira parts que la loi taubira soit
abrogée et qu'on ait une vraie politique
de sécurité dans notre pays un bon camp
sur la loi sur l'état d'urgence
si vous prononcez pour combien de temps
c'était d'ailleurs j'en parle de trois
mois ça peut être six mois mais ça veut
dire que s'apprête à l'infini donc prêt
dans un état d'urgence permanent
écoutez d'abord l'état d'urgence est
sous contrôle des juges administratifs
donc c'est pas l'état d'urgence n'est
pas le patriot act américain de bush on
en fait un monde
l'état d'urgence permet tout juste de
fonctionner tout juste et il est vital
après si on veut pour l'avenir moi je
propose de nouvelles lois pénales
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut abroger la loi
taubira simplifier le travail de la
police
et là on pourra se passer de l'état
d'urgence c'est pourquoi il ya l'état
d'urgence c'est parce que on a mis en
place des règles judy
hier ingérable et que la police ne peut
plus fonctionner en l'état de notre
droit
voilà et donc on contourne la complexité
l'inertie judiciaires françaises de
l'art l'état d'urgence chansons qu'il
faudrait juste leur revient sur l'état
d'urgence
si on veut se passer de l'état d'urgence
il faut revoir nos lois pénales non pas
pour enlever le contrôle judiciaire
parce qu'on a besoin de magistrats qui
font leur travail mais pour faire en
sorte que la justice et la police mills
travailler correctement ça déchire
l'ensemble des chances de nationalité
belge déchéance nationale comprend plus
rien dans la déchéance de nationalité
elle ne vaut que pour les binationaux
quand on est binational et qu'on a une
autre nationalité
si on se comporte mal on dégage donc
vous la voterons la mesure où la vôtre
et à mesure n'est bien évidemment pas ce
que c'est le bon sens d'ailleurs je
remarque que les belles âmes qui sont
contre la déchéance de nationalité
elle a été employée par la république
pour se défendre face aux esclavagistes
face aux collaborateurs alors moi je ne
vois pas pourquoi on fait tout un on en
a beaucoup trop parlé c'est pas la
mesure essentielle mais éloignement sur
un territoire lointain des français et
les étrangers ou les binationaux qui ne
respectent pas notre pays est bien sont
expulsés pour votre information réforme
pénale les lois d'application de la
révision constitutionnelle mercredi
devant le conseil des ministres que ça
ça fait bien on va quitter quelques
temps un petit peu ce le côté
parlementaire pour arriver sur le côté
un petit peu plus politique
on va parler de littérature ou presque
tous les candidats à la primaire de
droite décidé de prendre la plume
c'est le cas notamment de nicolas
sarkozy qui aimait là une forme de mea
culpa
regardez à dix mois de la primaire de la
droite et du centre c'est un livre
surprise très attendu nicolas sarkozy
n'est pas officiellement candidat mais
multiplie désormais ses déplacements
pour rencontrer les français et surtout
dressé son propre bilan
le bilan ou l'inventaire sera pareil
pourquoi parce que dans le mot
inventaire il ya un côté on sort le
suivi et on flingue et je trouve que ce
type de procédure de procéder pour
parler de ce que nous avons
collectivement faire ensemble n'est pas
une bonne idée que l'on fasse à un bilan
objectif
neutre quantifier les choses me paraît
indispensable que l'on se serve entre
guillemets du mot inventaire pour
réguler les contenus d'une façon ou
d'une autre me paraît une très mauvaise
idée bilan ou inventaire pour le moment
aucun extrait n'a filtré une stratégie
avec un air de bataille pour contrer les
mauvais sondages
selon atlantico ou aux docks ça c'est
toujours la même musique
alain juppé fait seule la course en tête
nicolas sarkozy s'exprimera dimanche
soir à la télévision pour décrypter lui
même les réussites et les erreurs de son
quinquennat sans doute plus sommes pas
allés assez loin je pense à la durée du
travail 35 heures je pense aux charges
qui pèsent sur les entreprises la
fameuse tva sociale
tout cela mérite qu'on en parle et je
pense que c'est très attendue par les
français se serait expliqué sur un peu
droit dans les yeux entre l'ancien
président la république et les français
au delà des livres c'est bien qu'ils
aient une compétition d'éditeur je pense
qu'il faudrait que les républicains
organise dès maintenant le débat des
idées c'est ça le sujet le parti
pourrait au même moment et ça serait
moins hypocrite organiser un débat d
idées que les français attendent le
combat des livres ne fait que commencer
après françois fillon alain juppé et
bientôt nicolas sarkozy électeurs ont
déjà rendez vous avec bruno le maire ou
hervé mariton
nicolas du point je vous présente j'ai
raté notre partenaire du scan bonjour à
vous interroger d'ici quelques secondes
moi j'avais deux questions à vous poser
concernant ce retour et ce livre de
nicolas sarkozy il dit je suis pas c'est
allé assez loin sur les 35 heures ni
charlie sf
donc c'est un regret et deuxièmement il
dit qu'il a abîmé la fonction
présidentielle
avec cette fameuse phrase prononcée sur
l'agriculture le casse-toi pauv' con
est ce que il a abîmé la fonction
présidentielle est ce que vous estimez
aussi je vais vous dire je regardais
votre reportage et je me faisais une
réflexion ils ont construit un bateau
pendant 20 ans si on construit la france
d'aujourd'hui
le bateau coule et ils vont nous
expliquer qu'il faut les reprendre
mais attendez ya plus un français qui a
envie de revoir toutes ces têtes la
relève nicolas sarkozy ne veulent que
les ours mais attendait qu'ils ont été
premier ministre président de la
république
ministre ils n'ont pas été capables de
faire des choses pires ils ont construit
un système qui ne marche pas et qui est
responsable de souffrance de millions de
français
et ces gens là passent leur vie à nous
expliquer qu'ils vont faire bien la
prochaine fois mais qu'il faut savourer
n'est pas à moitié pardonnée nick non
mais attendez que nous sommes la seule
démocratie au monde qui fonctionne comme
ça il n'y a pas un pays au monde qui
accepte que des gens qui ont gouverné
longuement qui avait tous les pouvoirs
et échoué et veuille revenir et ce qui
n'est pas temps de proposer aux français
une autre voie c'est ce que je ferais
que le mot compagnie et je peux vous
assurer une chose tout ça c'est fini ça
ne m'impressionne plus du tout ce sont
des livres de souvenirs
voilà le mariage pour tous par exemple
il dit que s'il revient il n'abroge
rappaz mais la loi sur le mariage pour
nice mais que les français n'ont pas du
tout envie de le voir revenir
donc ce sont des livres de souvenirs
voilà je les prends comme des leviers et
art usham interrégional souvenir mais ça
ne m'intéresse pas du tout parce que les
états d'âme de gens qui ont mal gouverné
la france qui ont signé les accords
européens scandaleux qui ont tué
l'europe et on va en parler qui ont créé
des millions de chômeurs qui ont été
corrompus pour certain e tout flamme
m'intéresse pas en tout cas je suis très
mauvais souvenir comment au rayon des
souvenirs au rayon oui des souvenirs et
aux fonds de la bibliothèque ça finira
chez les bouquinistes sur les quais de
la seine alors on l'a compris et un
autre à droite pardonnez moi mais il ya
un autre à droite qui a reçu rejet aussi
lui sur les plateaux de télévision c'est
jean françois copé voilà après dix-huit
mois de silence médiatique il se
présente en victime en bouc émissaire
après laffaire bygmalion à la guerre
pour la présidence de l'ump alors est ce
que pour vous il fait partie de ces îles
que vous désignez ce qu'il est toujours
dans le coup jean-françois combien j'ai
pas à donner des brevets je vous dis que
moi en tant qu'homme politique élu local
qui voit vraiment le le naufrage du pays
et c'est ça qui me qui me m'angoisse me
fait vivre c'est d'essayer de me dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour changer de
trajectoire
vous pouvez me reconnais que j'ai pas
changé d'avis que j'ai alerté que j'ai
quitté l'ump jaequi
et tous ces gens là les français ont le
droit de veto mais les français ont tout
à fait le droit d'aimer des gens qui les
ont ruiné si ça leur fait plaisir me
demandez pas moi de les admirer même si
je respecte les personnes et chacun a le
droit de venir faire ce qu'il veut mais
la situation est tellement grave de
notre pays mais les régionales sont il
ya on a l'impression qu'il ya un siècle
mais ce que vous rendez compte de ce
qu'est en train de se produire les
activités s'en vont nos agriculteurs
crève
voilà ce qui m'intéresse comment on
redresse l'agriculture française comment
on dit redeviens fière de notre pays
comment créer un million d'emplois on
relocalise un million d'emplois
c'est ce qui m'intéresse ce sont pas des
gens qui ont créé les problèmes internes
vont les résoudre c'est ce que disait
einstein il n'était pas complètement
idiot engine
allez on passe à la loupe du scan jim
c'est un beau bonjour nicolas dupont
aignan on l'a vu nicolas sarkozy vient
de publier son livre il est pas le seul
jean-françois copé et françois fillon
alain juppé
le prochain c'est vous oui de sortir ali
mais c'est pas du tout pareil pourquoi
parce que moi je vais expliquer pourquoi
j'ai rompu avec ces gens là
pourquoi ils ont tué la france à petit
feu avec ceux de la gauche là tout ce
petit monde qui travaille en oligarchie
et qui donne des leçons à la terre
entière et je vais présenter un
traitement de choc pour mon pays que
j'aime le programme viendra un peu plus
tard mais un ce sera un livre personnel
où elle dit des plus personnels parce
que souvent j'ai remarqué que les gens
me disais mais pourquoi vous avez quitté
ces gens là ils ne comprennent pas la
pourriture de ce système
ils ne comprennent pas l'esprit
d'abandon qui a régné ils ne comprennent
pas que des hommes politique
intelligente puisse à ce point trahir la
france eh ben je vais leur expliquer
dans mon livre ce qu'ils ont fait et
qu'est ce qu'il faut changer devoir
d'explication sur ce cui parce que j'ai
le sentiment que dans le zapping
permanent et ce n'est pas de votre faute
parce que vous faites votre métier avec
l'époque que vous avez comme nous dans
ce zapping médiatique permanent on perd
deux on perd le fond des choses et le
fond des choses c'est quoi c est ce que
notre pays dans la mondialisation
sauvage
bref inhumaines où on va fabriquer des
enfants en inde où l'ozone des femmes ou
où la planète est en train d'exploser
devant nous est ce que notre pays avec
ses valeurs son histoire peut changer
les choses et se sauver lui-même et se
sauve en lui-même est ce qu'il peut
infléchir la marche du monde
c'est fondamental et moi j'aimerais
qu'on parle de la politique à 20 ans et
se livre enfin tout cas j'étais en train
de l'écrire je le fun lilas il est prêt
j'ai mis beaucoup de temps j'ai mis un
an à l'écrire jeu j'essaye en tout cas
de me dire qu'est ce que je veux pour
mon pays dans 20 ans et comment on peut
changer de cap c'est comme un bateau qui
va vers le mauvaise direction et comment
on va pouvoir redresser les choses voilà
et vous verrez si ça vous intéresse il
faut que là j'espère que ça sera des
gens c'est pourquoi j'espère je dois
leur maître le 5 février si vous m'en
laisser le temps et j'espère sortie vers
mi mars
j'avais trouvé un titre gea titre mais
qui plaît pas l'éditeur mais il me plaît
moi donc ça serait quoi je vous le dirai
pas
est ce que c'est une étape obligatoire
avant une éventuelle candidature à la
présidentielle
c'est pas c'est une étape indispensable
personnel pour clarifier ses idées et
expliquer à nos concitoyens le sens d'un
combat en tout cas moi je pense ça donne
quand il est bien sûr mais je ne le
serais lancé par être candidat je n'en
sais rien encore vous le verrez le
moment venu mais ça se précise c'est
clair en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que je ne peux pas aller devant les
français sans d'abord avant avoir
expliqué le sens de ce combat que nous
sommes je pense des millions à partager
et la situation est tellement grave et
et en contrepartie l'agitation
superficielle d'un milieu politique est
tellement pathétique que le contraste me
paraît de nature à créer en 2012 vous
avez fait un vieux lui pour sont des
vrais est ce que si vous êtes candidat
en 2007 vous pensez pouvoir réunir plus
d'électeurs coûté j'en ai déjà réuni
plus puisque européennes régionales
nous avons été auprès de 4 % des voix
près d'un million d'électeurs s'est pas
encore assez mais pour quelqu'un qui
n'est pas invitée dans les jt
les journaux télévisés de tf1 de france
2 et qui enfin bill vision venir mille
fois moins que les autres je trouve que
c'est déjà beaucoup
que marié par exemple bien sûr mais
qu'importe vous savez dans la vie ce qui
compte c'est l'authenticité et c'est
d'avoir des solutions parce
qu'aujourd'hui les français ne croient
plus les hommes politiques ils ont
tellement été trompée et ils attendent
des solutions sincère et cohérente et ce
travail sur les solutions permettra
d'avoir un vrai débat avec même ceux qui
font des livres de souvenirs ne soyons
pas intolérants un vrai débat et puis
après c'est aux français de juger votre
objectif c'est de créer une voie
intermédiaire entre les républicains et
le front national c'est ça votre votre
positionnement et votre vends mon
objectif c'est de sauver mon pays et je
considère que on l'a vu dans la sphère
de la région nord pas de calais paca que
le front national est une sorte de
dérivatif utilisé par le système pour se
maintenir éternellement au pouvoir et je
considère que même si le front national
dit des choses justes puisqu'il a repris
des thèmes boulistes seguini ce qu'on
défend des je considère que les français
ont besoin d'une voix patriotique plus
constructive plus raisonnable plus
sereine plus crédible et c'est ce
nouveau patriotisme que je veux
présenter alors l'offre le front
national parlons-en marque marine le pen
elle est vraiment dans les starting
blocks pour 2017
il ya une question qui se pose au fn en
ce moment c'est pour ou contre la sortie
de l'euro pardon c'est une proposition
qui a été formulée en 2012 de manière
assez fermé et on a l'impression que le
fn est un peu en train de changer son
fusil d'épaulé
louis aliot cette semaine disait dans le
figaro refaire la campagne de 2010 2012
en 2017 ça n'a aucun intérêt
est-ce que vous pensez que le fn est en
train de renoncer au souverainisme
économique pour des intérêts électoraux
électoralistes je sais pas mais moi je
suis surpris j'ai lu cette interview et
j'ai le sentiment tout à coup que le
front national reprend en grossissant
les méthodes des deux autres partis
c'est à dire il ne se dit pas qu est ce
qui est bon pour la france il se dit
qu'est ce que je dois faire pour gagner
et ce faisant il dit
comme les autres nous à deux bouts la
france et je suis pas seul il ya des
beaucoup de gens qui nous accompagnent
on se pose une seule question qu'est ce
qui est bon pour notre pays la sortie de
l'euro oui ou non pour vous la
transformation de l'euro qui irait vers
comme pour schengen un démantèlement
vous avez également évoluer en 2012 vous
disiez sortie de l'euro sortie de l'euro
mais cette sortie de l'euro n'est pas
comprise et elle a été instrumentalisée
contre nous je dis que l'on peut tout à
fait retrouvé une flexibilité monétaire
et j'ai proposé c'est pas nouveau
j'avais proposé en 2012 mais ça c'est
pas vu donc j'ai pas changés l'euro
flexible c'est à dire leur offrant leurs
marques etc
c'est une monnaie qui permet la
flexibilité j'ai tout mais là je n'ai
pas changé
merci nicolas dupont mère sa fille jim
on va passer à tout autre chose vous
êtes aussi un élu de l'essonne
département dans la dette a explosé ces
derniers temps la droite dallas remis en
cause et bien toute la gestion de
l'ancienne majorité on a reçu sur ce
plateau
serge dassault du groupe dassault comme
côté cesta sénateurs lui aussi du
département écouter ce qu'ils disaient
c'est quand même invraisemblable les ça
nous oblige à payer plus de réserves
obligatoires et tous sont nous enlevons
les dotations qui nous donnait il
donnait à tout le monde d'ailleurs
régions départements et communes
alors on a moins d'argent à dépenser et
puis là on se dépense on le confesse
augmenter les impôts et le rsa moi je
considère que si les deux savent
augmenter leur essence et lui a payé
s'est passé pour dépassement est pas
possible ce n'est pas possible 108
millions de dettes 29 % de hausse du
du foncier c'est impossible à gérer pour
les départements ah oui je connais bien
le président du conseil départemental
qui est quelqu'un que je connais très
bien qui a travaillé avec moi qu'il en
soit durerait qui est quelqu'un de
courageux et et donc qu'il se débat dans
une situation impossible
mais est ce qu'il faut pour autant
après avoir laissé les socialistes ruiné
l'essonne que la droite ruine les
essonniens et j'écoutais serge dassault
qui est toujours le chantre de la baisse
d'impôts et qui va augmenter les impôts
de 29% mais ça va pas la tête
alors moi je le dis très amicalement à
mes amis de l'essonne battez vous contre
le gouvernement ne tombaient pas dans ce
piège monstrueux ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que en fait une fois de
plus des gens raisonnables et honnête
vont envoyer la facture de ceux des
socialistes qui n'ont pas été correctes
il ya 108 millions à régler quand il ya
plus que 108 ya une dette d'un milliard
etc
mais moi je demande je suis très surpris
comment dire là aussi de l'esprit de
résignation des présidents de conseils
départementaux
en tout cas si j'étais président d'un
conseil départemental
on entendrait un peu plus et je ferai la
grève des du rsa il faut payer le rsa
blement ce ski est à l'état de payer oui
mais ils ne font pas voyez vous avez
dans cette interview de fer d'assaut le
résumé parfait de la droite qu'on ne
veut plus c'est à dire une droite qui
avant les élections promet des baisses
d'impôts qui se trouvent confrontés à
une difficulté et qui se couche et bien
moi j'estime que c'est pas aux
essonniens de payer 29% de plus de taxes
foncières
je reconnais la difficulté dans lesquels
ils sont mais j'estime qu'il devrait ne
plus payer le rsa l'état c'est à l'état
d'assumer son assistanat
quant au rsa il ya du rsa justifiée mais
il ya du rsa de fraude notamment des
étrangers va s'en occuper
abbas à l'europe mais l'europe il en
était question jeudi nicolas dupont
aignan à davos en suisse
plusieurs chefs d'état et de plusieurs
chefs de gouvernement européens ont fait
le déplacement dans la petite station
d'hiver huppé c'était le cas notamment
david cameron alexis ce type race ou
encore manuel valls parmi d'autres une
première pour un premier ministre
socialiste il a lancé un message
d'alarmé sur l'état de l'europe
écoutez ça aura été une erreur
historique mortels pôle europe si nous
avions laissé partir la grèce de la zone
euro
je crois que dans la période que nous
vivons voir partir la grande bretagne de
l'union européenne serait un drame
serait un drame terrorisme afflux de
réfugiés
l'europe est menacée aujourd'hui de
dislocation mais tout ce que vous avez
dit depuis longtemps qu'il avait un
temps que je vous le dis j'ai commencé
ma carrière politique avec philippe
séguin manière par le rogue aujourd'hui
mais l'union européenne les institutions
je voudrais vraiment qu'on dise aussi
l'union européenne de l'europe l'europe
c'était quoi
c'était la paix et c'est l alliance de
nation démocratique travaillent ensemble
l'union européenne a kidnappé
l'idée européenne elle l'a trahi c'est
une bande de gens corrompus et
incapables qui ont créé le chaos
migratoires et le marasme économique
et il s'étonne que ça ne marche pas ils
sont responsables tous ces gens à davos
donc on peut reconstruire l'europe moi
je ne suis pas contre l'europe je suis
pour reconstruire l'europe des nations
et des peuples sur des projets de
coopération comme on l'a fait airbus
faisons le sur la voiture propre sur la
lutte contre le cancer sur les
nanotechnologies sur l'espace sur la mer
et abandonnons ses institutions
donc le break site c'est très bien
mettons fin à cela et recouvrer son
l'europe pour les européens mais en
simple et ben voilà
ce sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
mieux merci d'avoir été notre invité à
ce prochain
vos rendez vous avec public sénat